accurate forecast on 8 News Now
well that storm system is still sweeping
through the East and mostly off the east
coast today but the snow still swirling
in the plains in the Upper Midwest we'll
take a look in just a moment as we look
out here across the valley you see that
Haze right there that unfortunately is a
byproduct of very light winds and cold
air and that's what we've got today
there is high pressure over the west but
it's kind of Trapped the colder air over
the Great Basin in the southwest
temperatures struggling just to make it
into the upper 40s and near 50 degrees
right now at noon humidity just about 30
percent it's been windy up in the spring
mountains and Kyle Canyon has been in
the 30s since early this morning 48
right now at Red Rock Indian Springs
that number is should be 46 so I
apologize there not 26 49 in Pahrump 53
in Mesquite 30 still for Caliente and
Ely is still in the 20s 34 for Tonopah
Reno right around freezing at the noon
hour 52 in Boulder City and 55 in
Laughlin so we're looking to increase
the temperatures maybe just a couple of
degrees today yesterday we were 52
normal is 56 Sunrise was 6 45 and 427 is
the sunset boy these mornings have been
cold Pahrump you've been down in the 20s
want to share a wonderful picture from
Davey Matthews who Fosters about 13
feral cats of course they don't come
indoors they stay out and she puts out
heating pads on the patio and the under
the carport and she's got a two-story
condo and a Kitty houses for them and
even heated water bowls for the cats and
the birds so thank you Davey for all you
do to take care of those outdoor kitty
cats got to stay warm in these cold cold
mornings so there's the snow still
swirling around that low and here is the
rain and the freezing rain up in the
Northeast but now the severe weather is
focusing on Florida tornado watches
flood warnings with heavy rain that line
of showers and thunderstorms will
eventually move off the coast later
today so we've got cold air and some of
those those high clouds that move in
from California but a lot of them have
been thinning out and freeze watch a
hard freeze watch for Central Mohave
County Friday night into Saturday
morning as cold air returns with a
little disturbance tomorrow that's going
to pick up those Northerly breezes again
temperatures will drop to the upper 40s
but next week as we finish off fall and
head into winter Heather a warming Trend
upper 50's even low 60s Before Christmas
weekend so maybe we can thaw out a
little bit yeah I mean I'm not
complaining it's just so funny so ironic
in the first oh go figure